elle a appris que le périmètre de
sécurité avait été retiré à laure olga
le naias est approché en silence du
bataclan avec son violent et elle a joué
jouer pour ceux qui étaient à
l'intérieur
il faut continuer de faire de la musique
dit-elle car la musique est un langage
qui unit les gens devant la salle de
spectacle les fleurs les bougies et les
messages continuent de s'accumuler
à peine de retour en france elodie est
venu s'y recueillir
caporal-chef dans l'armée française elle
revient tout juste d'une mission anti
terroriste au tchad et au niger
si différent quand on va les soeurs
quand c'est son propre pays qui se fait
attaquer on ressent pas de la même façon
on va se battre
on peut pas se laisser abattre par ce
qu'il s'est passé
ne pas se laisser abattre c'est pour
cela que le café des anges a rouvert ses
portes
mais l'ambiance ici n'est pas à la fête
et pour cause
vendredi soir ou d'assad in serveuse ici
fêté son 35e anniversaire elle avait
invité et sa soeur à lima ses collègues
ses amis à célébrer l'événement au bar
la belle équipe
onze d'entre eux sont morts sur cette
terrasse fauchés par des rafales de
kalachnikov
la crise guillaume romain michelli sont
des noms qui résonnent ici cruellement
absents
et pourtant tellement présent en buvant
un verre juste avant justement ça se
passe en hiver ensemble elle est partie
et ont besoin clin d'oeil
je me souviens de sa comme tous ici
morgane marc elle essaie de se
concentrer sur son travail mais
certaines questions reviennent sans
cesse
maj monde s'ils ont souffert si ça a été
radical si son lutteur saisir eu le
temps d'avoir peur si
comprendre ce qui leur arrivait mais le
monde forcément ça ce que j'essaie
d'imaginer la scène savoir comment ça
s'est passé
en réaction aux attentats un mot clic
est devenue virale sur internet tous au
bistrot un mot d'ordre s'asseoir à la
terrasse d'un café pour résister pour ne
pas se laisser intimider
et si jean françois bélanger radio
canada